foreign
welcome to this new video by simply
learn search engines are the powerful
tool that allows user to quickly and
easily find information on internet they
provide access to the enormous amount of
data which would otherwise be impossible
to navigate and sort through manually
from research to shopping entertainment
to education search engines have become
an integral part of Modern Life the most
popular search engines use complex
algorithms to analyze and index web
pages allowing them to deliver relevant
results to users based on their queries
the process of ranking and displaying
these results is continually evolving
making search engine optimization also
known as SEO an essential aspect of
online business and marketing in this
era of information overload search
engines are in dispensable for anyone
seeking to navigate the vast expanse of
Internet efficiently so hey everyone if
you are looking to grab such a golden
opportunity then you should definitely
look at the professional certificate
program in digital marketing some key
features of this program include master
classes by Purdue ask me anything
sessions industry projects and more you
will be benefited from the in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
research and more so what are you
waiting for hurry up and find the course
Link in the description box below listen
to what millions of users are saying
about our courses find the simple learn
course reviews Link in the description
box so without any further Ado here we
have a question for you how many search
engine algorithms do you know list their
names in the comment section below and
get a heart from Simply learn also don't
forget to subscribe simply learn and hit
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply learn so without any further
Ado let's start by understanding search
engine algorithms a search engine
algorithm is a complex set of rules and
formulas used by search engines to
determine the relevance and importance
of web pages in response to a user's
search query the algorithms takes into
account various factors such as keywords
content quality website architecture
user behavior and many other factors to
determine the ranking of web pages in
search engine result Pages or Subs
search engines like Google Bing and
Yahoo regularly update their algorithms
to improve the quality of search results
and prevent the spammy or low quality
content from ranking high in search
results these updates are often
accompanied by algorithmic penalties and
algorithmic filters which can affect the
visibility and ranking of websites that
fail to meet the search engines quality
standard as a website owner or a digital
marketer it is important to stay up to
date with the latest search engine
algorithm updates and optimize your
website accordingly to improve its
visibility and ranking and search
results ahead in this video Let's
understand the types of search engine
algorithms there are several types of
search engine algorithms each with its
own unique approach to ranking and
displaying search results here are some
of the most common types the number one
we have is crawlers or spiders these
algorithms use both to crawl the web and
index web pages based on their content
keywords and other factors the next we
have is semantic search this type of
algorithm attempts to understand the
meaning of search query and the content
on the web pages to provide more
relevant search results the next we have
is pagerank this algorithm is developed
by Google and it assigns a score to web
page based on the number and quality of
links pointing to them the next we have
is personalized search these algorithms
take into account of a user's search
history location and other data to
provide search results tailored to their
individual's preferences
the next we have is natural language
processing this type of algorithm uses
machine learning and artificial
intelligence to understand natural
language queries and provide more
accurate search results the last one we
have is knowledge graphs these
algorithms aim to provide answers to
specific questions by drawing on the
structured data and building a knowledge
graph of entities relationships and
Concepts overall search engines use a
combination of these algorithms and more
to provide the best possible search
results to the users in this video we
are specifically going to focus on the
page rank algorithm page rank is an
algorithm developed by Google's
co-founders Larry Page in 1998 as a part
of the research project in Stanford
University the algorithm is used to
determine the relevance or importance of
a web page based on the links pointing
to it the basic idea behind pagerank is
that Pages importance is determined by
number of quality of other pages that
link to it in other words the more links
a page receives from other high quality
Pages the more important it is deemed to
be to calculate the page rank of a page
the algorithm considers both the number
and the quality of inbound links or
backlinks as well as the page rank of
the linking Pages it assigns a numerical
value to each page with higher values
indicating the greater importance the
algorithm works by treating each page a
node in a network with the links between
the pages representing the edges this is
an iterative algorithm to calculate the
page rank values for each page in the
network
here is the formula for the page rank
algorithm the basic page rank algorithm
is as follows it starts with a set of
web pages and assigns an initial page
rank value to each page next it
calculates the page rank of each page
based on the page rank of the pages that
links to it it updates the page rank of
each page based on the damping factor
which represents the probability that a
user will continue browsing randomly
rather than following a link it repeats
Step 2 and 3 until the page rank values
for each page covers a stable state
pagerank has become an important aspect
of Google search algorithms although the
exact detail of how it is used are not
publicly disclosed it is also used in
other applications such as social
network analysis and recommendation
systems in conclusion the page rank
algorithm is a crucial tool for ranking
web pages in search engine results it
works by assigning a score to each page
based on the number and quality of links
pointing to it patreon considers the
importance of not only the links
pointing to the page but also the
importance of pages those links are
coming from it uses a mathematical
formula that calculates the probability
would reach a particular Page by
following links from the other Pages
while the page rank has been modified
and improved over the years it remains a
fundamental part of Google's ranking
algorithm it is important for a website
owners to understand how page rank works
and to develop the strategies for
improving their website score this can
be achieved through various techniques
such as creating high quality content
obtaining backlinks from reputable
sources and optimizing the website
structures and metadata overall the
pagerank algorithm has had a significant
impact on the way we search for
information online and its importance is
likely to continue into the future as
search engines become increasingly
sophisticated let's wrap up this topic
with the hearty promise to come back
again with another interesting topic of
SEO if you like this video do share it
with your family and friends and
subscribe to Simply learn for more
updates thanks for watching this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign